hello I'm Rob Lowe although I'm not a  doctor I do play one on TV and today I'm  gonna play  operation see I can diagnose this  already this man has a toilet in his  belly  normally I won't wear gloves doing this  first I will extract we have the smiley  face growth which I just put back on his  body  oh how did it no sound has been made yet  which means that I'm succeeding  it's amazing how I do this you didn't  hear that well you can see why kids are  riveted to this to this day and I'm  getting faster oh this is for via the  med school get you have killed the  patient okay we only got one left we got  somebody it's like how did Boris do he  plays the surgeon sometimes you have to  turn the patient upside down and shake  it out of him and he's cured another  patient saved